what is the biggest red flags you guys
see in girls
she doesn't offer to pay her share in
the first date i disagree with you on
that
i think it's a great red flag look at it
that's fine
i don't think that's that big of a deal
she doesn't offer to pay on a first date
no because she's not entitled to my time
all my money yeah but sometimes guys
just offer to pay no no fight you for it
no
it's good though
it's good that a guy pays but i'm saying
it's
the lack of gesture is a red flag
the lack of gesture yeah because it goes
off sometimes i just feel really awkward
i'm gonna be honest sometimes i'm like
my guy so let's say you see a girl yeah
yeah and you turn and you asked her to
come on a date with me yep
you took her out of her own space i
didn't take her anywhere she chose to
come i hear that thank you she was
chilling like she wasn't
that that wasn't happening
like she loki wanted him to ask him
thank you she's not gonna she's not
gonna say yes if she doesn't wanna come
yeah she wanted to come but she wasn't
gonna ask him so he asked her all right
what i'm saying is
is you're you see a girl that you like
yep and you asked her that can't take
you on a date
you then feel like she should then also
pay no no i didn't say she should pay i
said she should she should offer no no
she should offer to pay her share
if i when i if i take girl if i ask a
girl out on a date
i'm always gonna pay
but i want her to offer to pay her share
that's what i was getting there i was
just making sure that
that was the main thing that you'd
always want to pay because you took it
out yeah but you just want to see like
if she would help out too
it's a lot it's for me it's just showing
it's it's a sign of appreciation she's
like
you don't have to do this for me
but i appreciate when you do
because she the things that she will do
that she doesn't have to do for me but
i'll appreciate like
if she
i know she cooks for me so it's not i'm
not like oh because you're a woman you
have to do that so i'm like oh thanks
baby i was super thankful and i was like
oh that's so nice like thank you so much
you would still think i was like
entitled
uh
because most guys just grab it no that's
what i'm saying yeah saying thank you
okay like being being appreciative okay
i'm not gonna fight you for it i won't
no but i'd be like oh no i don't mind if
you spit this i don't know it's okay
okay great thanks but i do
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to you i
do mind if you asked me no but it's just
it's just about it's just about it's
just about being polite it's just about
being boy that's how i say thank you
that's still polite yeah that's all
right that's all right
okay glad to know i wouldn't get i
wouldn't get sent packing
i don't say thank you but like if she
doesn't even say she doesn't offend she
doesn't even say thank you i i know the
vibe i'm taking you out again i know i
know the vibe you're talking about i get
it i'm not saying
my bad it's okay there's always this
happening sorry this happens i i think
if i think though if you if you start to
say that you think that um
women should pay half which by the way i
always think which is not what i'm
saying no no but i'm saying if you
expect a woman to at least offer even if
you say no
um i think then does that not imply that
you also talking back to the
expectations of what you want from a
woman does that then not just say you
don't just want a woman who's pretty and
in shape you know i want a woman who is
financially stable because no it's poor
i think yeah and polite but no but if a
woman wasn't financially stable she
would not offer because if you said yeah
all right and then she's like sure i've
got no money in my bank account but i
think i think it's the polite would you
agree with like it's because you want
her to be polite yeah i think i think if
i'm being honest i think part of it is
maybe i think i'm maybe a bit more uh
sensitive to that because the way i've
been raised is to always be grateful
when think people do things for you so i
think for me that's quite important we
were talking about this the other day
i'm like i think it's bad i prefer like
just hanging out over dates oh yeah you
talk about that today yeah yeah
that you would rather just like i
invited guys but it's not a good thing
i'm like i should like
coaching you absolutely not i know
because more because i'm lazy and so i'm
like
i'm like i gotta go downtown
i get put off if like say
i've met someone
online or in person and they're like oh
like without any sup uh um that they
don't provoke so they just go oh so um
where are you taking me to
like it it's a trigger for me instantly
like as soon as that said i don't want
to take out no more because like you
kind of expect me to just take out and
then all of a sudden pay you like a
cinderella kind of thing if that makes
sense
especially in an app oh my god that's
gonna keep the first date first date i'm
not trying to go out to like dinner
because what if okay what if i match
with you on an app okay
and you start sending me weird stuff you
know what i mean like straight away like
or like didn't you go out with him would
you well no i wouldn't but like i meant
like when i get there oh i said sending
sorry wrong word wrong word but like
what if i get there and like it's weird
like then i how am i to leave before i
had dinner you know what i mean
you're like am i supposed to go hungry
yeah that's that's why we have asked for
angela in england have you seen if
you've ever been i was going to say if
you've ever been in women's toilets you
probably haven't but um there's a they
always have to sing on the back saying
ask for angela so you can ask at the
back and you say oh is angela working
and they'll provide you a taxi back home
if you've got a date that's going south
really yeah
i've never known that yeah yeah yeah if
you've got
if you've got a date that's going south
and part of it is from a protection
point of view if this person is giving
you vibes of like this person is
potentially going to kidnap me and i
could end up buried in a ditch somewhere
but also if it's
free
i don't know see i don't think i think i
think if it's a case of if you ask i
think like a bargain
[Laughter]
i think it's probably at the pubs
discretion but i would imagine that it's
not free if you were just like i'm just
really not having a great i'm just you
know what i'm not feeling i know but i
could be like could you take me in my
day
i'm just saying i'm just i'm asking for
angela i grew up with a very cheap dad
okay
i love me a bargain
all right well i yeah
all right question for the ladies what's
uh what's a red flag
for you that you you see in the guy
first impressions
red flag
ah
um
if he tries to show me his mixtape
do people even have this
i used to i used to do i used to do rap
reactions so people used to oh really
no no um
seriously but like some rapper who's
you've done that with is watching this
like what the [ __ ]
no have i
in it no no um it's a real red flag um
i would say like if they're talking
about their past relationships and like
everything is the girl's fault or like
the girl's crazy
i'm like okay so either you like crazy
women okay
which isn't that's not good
i'm like then offensive why are you out
with me
or two or two like like you probably
cheat like because in my mind it's like
oh he's probably a cheater because
oh why are all these girls going crazy
like because i have brothers they date
and their girlfriends don't go crazy on
them because they're not they're not
cheaters i don't do that i have a
question you say something interesting
you like
did you like well the second thing
is that he's probably a cheater because
he made them crazy
if it's a pattern one off that's one
thing but if it's a pattern you're the
common denominator but
but why would you
why would you say
that if they're all crazy
it's because of him